hey what's up guys it's mkbhd so very
recently twitter rolled out to pretty
much all users their new activity tab in
twitter calm we know twitter doesn't get
a whole lot of updates you know Facebook
made major changes Google+ rolls out and
Twitter kind of stays the same
now there's a Google+ Timeline and
there's a Facebook Timeline and Twitter
finally has this activity tab that looks
a lot like a timeline so I thought no
further ado we'll go ahead and take a
video look at the latest feature for
Twitter to roll out activity all right
guys so here is the new Activity Stream
in action if you'd like to follow me on
Twitter by the way I am at mkbhd on
Twitter so that link will be in the
description for you guys either way the
first way to find it is of course up
here in the different tabs that are up
here on top of your Twitter feed also on
the right hand side under trends you can
see all activity and a couple of most
recent activities so this guy favorited
some tweets this guy followed this guy
followed two people and you can hit the
view all button and that'll bring you to
the activity link so that link will be
in the description as well just in case
you don't already have it and this is a
basic look at what it looks like you can
see who people are starting to follow in
real time so if you notice a bunch of
people are following a new person you'll
be able to see that you go to see the
pictures of the people that they're
following right now Twitter doesn't have
a whole lot going on besides tweets
mentions retweets and follows but that's
basically what they're going to detail
here in their activity feed so you can
see someone got followed someone got
followed someone it got replied to and
it's really cool you can see different
retweets and favorites it's interesting
to see what kind of things people
favorite because honestly I wasn't aware
that people still favorited a lot of
tweets but this is definitely something
you might want to check out also you'll
notice that when someone only follows a
small number of people for example
YouTube followed four people so you only
have the image here but if they follow
multiple people like maybe only two
people you get a link to maybe follow
them just in case you're interested so
this has looked pretty good see this guy
favorited one of my tweets very cool ah
now we're getting back to three four
days ago five days ago and it's still
all retweets file
and favorites so that's basically what
Twitter's got going on for it
if you guys have any questions about
this feel free to leave a comment I'm
honestly interested do you guys still
use Twitter a lot because I know I've
moved very very you know very
confidently over to Google+ kind of
minimalizing Facebook but I'm kind of
Mason basically just Twitter and Google+
now I don't know if you guys still use
Facebook looks a lot like the timeline
let me know what you think in the
comment section below thanks for
watching you know talk to you guys in
the next video peace